Sandra Bullock dazzles in red alongside
her bird box co-stars at the film's
premiere in New York City ET spoke with
the actress about her fears a common
theme throughout the movie I think my
dears probably the same as every other
human beings which is losing family did
you speak to Vivian and Julian I know
yes yes Legos Legos was a big thing yes
Oh tag catch yes I mean when you get to
little people that there's basically
three things that they like to do and
all three of those were done on set it's
like nothing I can express because how
many people would love to be able to
take their children to work and have
that embraced it's it's so accepted so I
feel like every set I work on has to
have sort of a familial aspect to it and
a safe feeling for family members and
you do better work the mother of two
says that she's always had a maternal
instinct I would have been pregnant I
would have been knocked up at 17 and my
mother knew that and she kept me under
lock and key I I wanted to be a mom at a
very young age so I kind of felt felt
the drive and the desire to Sandra also
dished on the potential of working again
with her oceans eight pal Sarah Paulson
we hope so we keep looking for like a
road trip movie where we're locked in a
vehicle preferably not during summer but
not Oh or no winter sort of like fall or
spring nice climate you know
no you got a time no I don't know
anything no one talks to me
[Music]